foreign
so we'll just pick up the conversation
we're having so like it seems like they
kill off Maggie Smith at the end right
the Downton Abbey movie but that was
your Countess it just stays alive so
they have to bring her back to the next
ones hello welcome to how this trailer
company she just inherited like an
Italian Villa right wasn't that the most
recent yeah they are literally at her
deathbed at the end of the first Downton
Abbey movie being like goodbye like we
all know you probably won't be back for
the next one still hanging on still
still doing great keep her down nah okay
uh we're talking about Avatar 2 today
don't worry we just wanted to finish
what we were talking about uh Avatar a
new era a new era
that's a whole other video Danielle
joining us from uh Los Angeles uh also
Lon joining me we are also in Los
Angeles and we're here to talk about the
honest trailer for Avatar 2 the way of
water uh we're gonna watch a trailer
together give you your our thoughts uh
behind the scenes a writing process Etc
we have some deleted scenes that we cut
from this one we also will take your
comments and questions so put those in
the chat and then we'll tease you with
next week uh not the Downton Abbey uh
one sad move to the Italian Villages I
wish it was the one
um but a similar film
isn't she in it
you're getting your Dames mixed up damn
I mean Dame uh let's talk about Avatar
actually we thought about two different
we switched off between two different
movies for next week both films feature
a day multiple Dames yeah wow so you do
there's your clue so many Dames I feel
like I'm in Guys and Dolls yeah
we're talking about Avatar 2 a blue
movie a very good Blue Movie
um maybe the blue is moving and perhaps
The Bluest film um James Cameron the
goat the king doesn't never misses uh I
mean when it comes to Blockbuster uh
entertainment he's like three of the top
five all-time movies it is a crazy shot
to call to be like this movie needs to
make like two billion dollars to just
turn a profit and then you make 2.3 that
is yeah that's like the the pointing
into the stands with the bat like of
Cinema Blockbuster filmmaking yeah it's
incredible I think that it's not
um he's this movie and the Avatar one I
think I'm not saying anything crazy that
it's not really you're you're there for
the holistic experience you're not there
for the groundbreaking story or
characters per se but you're there to be
transported
um and that's in the text itself is like
this is a movie about being transport to
a new cool looking world and he he does
exactly that he gets to scratch all of
his itches going under the sea so many
mini subs so many many Subs so getting
people wet and uh and sinking ships and
[__] like that and and nature itself
just nature is cool those are like his
themes and um I look I look I love it
for uh on its own terms which is which
is just that and uh what else is there
to say this is the the third biggest
movie of all time
as far as story and stuff goes uh who
cares but seeing it in IMAX in 3D like
that's how that's how I wanted that's
how I saw it yeah yeah
well no it's just one of those things
where it's like I don't I would be okay
if there was just one theater in town
that was always running his movies so
that I could go watch them the way that
I want to see them yeah and why did I
just mean I'm not buying a 3D T I'm not
Hector Navarro I'm not buying it and I
think I think that's okay it's all right
for Avatar movies to be like go see it
in 3D IMAX on the big screen it's
spectacle it's designed it's spectacle
and I think like we we sort of natively
have this like resistance to that like
no films are supposed to be about
enlightening and you know deep you know
like emotion and character like like I'm
glad every film isn't just Avatar and
some films are about that stuff but
every once in a while I think it's okay
for there to just be a three hour movie
that's about go see this yeah I'm
comparing this the colors are gonna pop
I'm comparing this more to
um like uh like a ride at Universal
Studios where you get in like a shaky
box and sometimes they spray you with uh
with fog when you go through the foggy
Cloud part
um more so than like banshees of to
Sharon although that would make for a
good shaky box right
with immersive
then it starts rumbling on the horse
carts when you tell somebody their
mother died yeah I don't want to chat
you're not interested real finger slice
in action like your hands start oh yeah
there's like the water the Water World
ride when the when the buy plane lands
it's just a guy that looks kind of like
Brandon Gleason
starts chucking fingers fingers at you
yeah
uh fully animatronic donkey but yeah
Avatar 2 I will say that um
something
like you said the story is not
revolutionary except it is revolutionary
in a very literal sense whereas I think
that you know I think Marvel
uh and DC and a lot of the pop culture
even Star Wars aside for mandor is not
is afraid to go there where it's like no
we need to kill the colonizers we need
to absolutely like they're irredeemable
except for like a few you know traders
that we keep around as pets like spider
but otherwise we need to kill kill them
and and go to war and like kill like
actually uh uh fight these people on in
very violent terms we're not talking it
out yeah we're not gonna like uh We're
not gonna come to some agreement we need
to go to guerrilla warfare against these
people to get them off our planet or
otherwise yeah they're going to destroy
the world I think you're you're tapping
into like I think like top gun Maverick
uh and a few other sort of recent
Blockbusters that we've had like it this
is moving away James Cameron doesn't do
the snarky deadpan that just happened
meta commenting on the movie that he's
making while he's making it
tongue-in-cheek ironic stuff that's the
opposite he's like the most sincere yeah
so sincere and like that's what I think
you're you're sort of talk about and
that this is so satisfying on some level
is that yeah this is hard on its sleeve
like he's not being subtle about what he
thinks and like this movie is like his
world view very clearly put forth in
every scene and it's very sincere and I
think like like that's refreshing in a
lot of ways because so many movies today
are not really about anything just about
like hey gonna get a load of this you
know yeah they pull their punches and
it's like you you know uh
Captain Marvel or whoever will be
working there'll be some bad apples
within the military industrial complex
you just gotta get rid of the badass
they don't want to commit because that's
not what that movie's about yeah right
so that at the end of like a falcon in
the Winter Soldier which should have
been a movie it's just Falcon trying to
give like the I Have a Dream speech but
his dream is maybe a little
militarization yeah it's like we need a
stronger HR at the secret government
Shadow industrial comp the big payoff
moment in his speech is do better
Senator do better Senator because
generally you have a specific whereas
James Cameron would put like a six foot
long like Arrow shaft through the
centers
would just fire a bow and arrow
yeah
uh so I do think in that sense he is
pushing or it is a little different from
your usual Blockbuster fare in that he's
willing to go there
um yeah it's a little bit a little bit
like the the George Lucas uh epics of a
generation before like he's got that
level of money and Prestige and power
where he gets to he doesn't have to
listen to Kevin feige he doesn't have to
take calls from David zaslav he's doing
what he wants yep and it shows you can
tell you'll love to see it uh let's
watch the Australia for Avatar the way
of water
foreign
six of seven comes a movie so expensive
it had to be the fourth biggest hit of
all time to make any money but when it
comes to sequels never bet against James
mother
[__] Cameron King of the [__]
world baby
Avatar the way of water
thank you remember Avatar won kinda
right something about blue elves having
ponytail sex with a flying dog well it's
back and this time they do it with a
fish horse join us with full-time data
what is your rejoinder or do you agree
with the criticism or comment that like
this has no cultural significance that
this was forgotten and just kind of came
and went and granted it did big box
office because like you could say
because 3D tickets are more expensive
and it was this like you have to see it
but it has it had no staying power or
has no staying power do you agree
disagree
um I disagree mostly I I don't let me go
ahead and just take you back to some
things that happened on the internet
when the first avatar came out
um people were having legitimate mental
breakdowns because they couldn't live on
Pandora as a Blue Tattoo there were
forums full and I'm sure that some of
them were people making fun of it and
that was funny as well but people were
literally like every day I wake up and
I'm not on Pandora as a day that I wish
I wasn't on this planet like Honduras
syndrome or something right it was a
real thing no it was a real thing and I
I just don't think that you can say
something doesn't have cultural and I I
guess for me it's what do you mean by
this has no cultural standing because I
feel like if this is a touch point and
it's a very specific moment that all of
us remember maybe we're not memeing the
movie we're not going around saying the
most classic Avatar lines but that's
also not what the movie is about on its
own thing and when you look at its
impact not just as the movie itself but
in the way that it ruined all future 3D
for all movies because people didn't do
it the way Cameron did and everyone
wanted to see it the way Cameron did and
then you'd go pay a million dollars for
a 3D movie and it would be crap like
when something has that big of an effect
on an entire industry I don't think that
that's fair to say it that you might not
like it you might think it's like
culturally you know like garbage but it
did affect the industry you have to take
the end again men crying because they
can't have blue ponytail sets it meant
something to people I mean I think it
goes back to sort of what we were saying
before like it's a different kind of
thing like it's not one of those movies
that people buy on Blu-ray maybe or like
a mainstream audiences they're not quote
watch over and over and over again but
that does that it's just a different
kind of thing it's a spectacle everybody
went to go see it in the theater and
it's a different kind of culture doesn't
have any that contributed to its its low
meme density I think was that uh
everyone was posting like Glass Onion
memes when this was out because they
didn't release this on digital a week
later right this was in theaters you
would have had to done the do the like
uh dubbed in Spanish like uh 480p screen
grab of it because you can only see this
in a 3D theater yeah I just think it's
just a different kind of movie event it
would be like saying well Star Tours
doesn't have any cultural relevance
because like people don't remember that
that's Captain Rex is your pilot
uh that's true
but it's like but of course Star Tours
has relatives we all been to Disneyland
and been on we all know Captain Rex we
all remember Captain Rex and his Paul
rubin's voices you know like uh but but
right it's like a different kind of
experience but that doesn't mean that we
didn't all enjoy it and and go on it
it's just yeah we don't remember it in
the same way that we remember you know
Big Lebowski quotes yeah yeah sorry it's
not Anchorman like all of the guys who I
worked with in the kitchen aren't going
back and forth saying you know like oh
you're my number one you're like sorry
it's not that it isn't something you can
say to make your friends laugh at a
party but it meant something what's your
favorite Avatar to quote that's all
let's say our favorite Avatar too oh
it's got it I know I know mine oh I
think mine is literally just bro
I can't believe I'm tied up again
that's me watching the movie
that deliberated
yeah
I mean there's nothing that's gonna for
me top unobtainium by the way what
happened to unobtanium
specifically has a line where she's like
we're not mining anymore yeah the new
goal is actually more colonizing all of
humanity so the first movie the goal was
not colonized they're just trying to
clear the ground for the right they're
just trying to dig up the unobtainium
now they're like Earth is screwed we
can't live there anymore permanently
Danielle my favorite quote was bro that
was insane cuz
everybody
like all of the Bros and cousins I was
like am I black and white one like
what's happening I also a great moment
not a line of dialogue but a classic
moment really Stephen Lang is amazing in
this it's like a fantastic mocap
performance he's really good he him
crushing his own skull human skull such
a perfect name Cameron beat I love that
he loves a crushed skull
just like the idea of a guy crushing his
oh a guy in a new body finding his dead
corpse and crushing his own skull I mean
as as James says uh why would I like
watch other movies when my own
imagination is so cool
that's the scene a guy who would say
that quote writes that's exactly that uh
all right let's keep going
or Jake Zoe a man who puts the Marine in
Aquamarine you disobey direct orders or
dismissed and white natiri just kind of
crying in the background this time
around
they'll move the family to space Florida
a Place full of racial tension even
though the water tribe is like one
crayon over but these soggy locals have
their own kinds of nature magic that let
them heal the sick commune with animals
and somehow manage to keep their dicks
and Blues from showing at all times a
marketeer it means double-sided tape I
mean pause they took this to the next
level we show the shots but like if you
have a loin cloth that's helicopter
resistant yeah wow
absolutely blowing and like I don't know
do you think he has the cachet for
Avatar 3 to just hang dong or or
are these cat-like people is it
retractable oh maybe maybe it's
subjectable oh just like a Ken doll down
there yeah yeah or yeah I like the idea
like avatar for because you know this is
going to be the format the sequels take
we're always gonna like go around the
world and find a new Zone new tribes new
groups uh so it'd be great if just they
show up and one of them just doesn't
wear like they just they're just the new
and then we spend five minutes with them
pulling on nope stop talking Danielle
all right let's keep going it's like a
full Doctor Manhattan the fire tribe
this Blue Man's crew start their lives
over in an obligatory underwater level
and even though some of the kids are
getting feels for teals it turns out
that the ocean Nobby kinda salty the
arms are thin
oh are weak still the silly Clan is here
to do two things learn about the gentle
customs of the sea people and get
kidnapped and they're all out of sea
customs
drop it
stop moving you want your kids back you
come out alone
I got your daughters same deal as before
remember a guy who keeps saying my
family is my Fortress maybe Jake should
I don't know hire a sitter
James Cameron must invent a whole new
culture for white actors to appropriate
with Kade Winslet just how Cameron likes
her wet and Sigourney Weaver who's
either chilling like an unopened jar of
pickled eggs or playing your teenage
self Curie the only one higher than you
when you watch this she's just looking
at the sun
huh
a tiny Tarzan who's lucky he was
abandoned on Pandora because back on
Earth he would just be Ross friend
[Music]
boy
so many things we could have played for
that I do have a intrusive thought since
that sketch came out of me toil part
time at the Cold Stone Creamery
at least once a month yeah really a real
struggle to be like which white guy with
dreads to compare him yeah because
you've got you got [__] Haze also
there's also in the lineup uh so Sublime
with Rome I think I wrote it some live
with Rome jokes
I almost put in a snow joke
um but I have recognized that no one
cares about informers the Informer yeah
um that would have worked yeah
I know that whole song
so yeah Justice for spider uh good for
him I think that it was
it was actually like mostly well done
that they could even integrate him at
all into shots like that just adds a
degree of difficulty that was not there
if it's all yeah let's just throw a real
boy
and it was mostly seamless so just just
pretty amazing
um what you can do with effects if you
give people time to get them right right
and if you if you if you actually think
about what's going to make this look the
best not what's going to make this look
okay with the three weeks we have to put
it together and I think that's the real
like it's not that we're you know coming
down on some VFX houses or artists it's
like it's all about the the planning and
the budget and the scheduling and the
time like I've given enough time people
since the 90s people could make right
James Cameron movies Starship Troopers
like they can make this look great they
just don't have the time they don't give
them the time I don't know if how much
of Star Wars celebration stuff you guys
watched but like it's become a it's
become a Trope now that that people on
new Star Wars shows and films come out
and be like we're not in the volley we
built we build
I was on a set it was real I touched it
we weren't on the like four different
projects were like we did James Bengal
just like I promise you Indiana Jones we
were in a cave
it's hard to imagine from Disney just a
few years ago
they were gonna be the opposite we did
it in this egg baby we're marketing the
volume they thought it was going to be
this huge thing I did a junket for The
Lion King and that's all Favre wanted to
talk about it was just volume all day
long right because he was like so
psyched about it and now when like it
happened and yeah yeah like now we're
and like we're marketing it based on
it's not in the egg we did it on a real
set
I mean you know I'm sure you can use it
sparingly but like when the entire
Show's in there it just looks like even
if you're in two different galaxies it
looks like you're in the big egg
um the cool lighting yeah all right keep
going Kiri must face their daddy issues
his dad is a homicidal maniac her dad is
probably an ancient tree goddess either
way neither one is paying child support
and don't forget Jake's rebellious on
log and Outcast Outcast who bonds with a
whale equivalent of a fedora kid he's
Outcast and the responsible son nateam
or wait was long The Good Son which one
is which again
it doesn't help that they all talk like
prank YouTubers from 2013. I got this
bro bro bro bro dude bro bro bro come on
come on bro bro come on
that was insane cause bro that was
insane cuz bro I'm good go oh sick
somehow I I one thing to bear in mind
remember they're all speaking uh the
native in the v language it's just weird
yeah like uh at one point Jake says like
dudes just started sounding like English
which I was smart sure I get yeah
Papyrus subtitles are more expensive I
get it but uh but so what so that's
being translated there's a navi word
that means cuz bro bro we're just
hearing the the English language
equivalents I wonder what those words
are uh bro
yeah I
there's a social experiment here's a
question I'll I'll put to the group
um I mean plot wise not in like the real
sense of things but uh Jake Sully too
many kids
too many kids or was it smart to have
that many because you got a spare to
kill off too many kids yeah too many
kids right because there were four right
well I guess Kyrie's like two two well
one is and spiders sort of uh yeah he's
got he's got it right that's what I was
gonna say spiders and is sort of
unofficially a kid yeah and then Kyrie's
adopted and then three and then
biological that's asking a lot for us to
to get to know and keep straight but it
does give you the ability to take out
the spare for for uh for the payoff at
the end you can do the wrong kid died
beat yeah but they also I was
legitimately like confused like when
they leave he like makes some other dude
the king of the forest tribe or
something like that and I was like which
son which son did he do what who was
that yeah I don't know is that a
character from the first avatar maybe I
don't think they explained I don't think
they explained well and if you because
if you think about how many years it had
been since the first avatar I don't even
know if that dude would have been more
than like a kid at that point so it's
been a little while another guy in the
first avatar who doesn't die who's like
the the guy who at first gives Jake crap
about it like that is probably him
initial rival who then becomes an ally
by the end of the movie his ice man he
died yeah does that guy die
I thought he died okay he might die yeah
he might die but anyway I was thinking
maybe it's that guy if he didn't die or
maybe it's that guy's son even could be
yeah well hey if again if you're
suffering from Pandora syndrome hey call
this number on your screen uh but we
loved you on how to with John Wilson
yeah
uh who is the who's the new king of the
of the Jungle yeah who takes over the
forest tribe look it up on fandom I'm
sure we've got a Wiki The omatakaya yes
all right keep playing
Orange has returned and like any other
Disney character who gets older dies
he's been replaced by a CG version of
himself now he's got a Strike Team of
the bluest meanies money can buy and the
ability to instantly find whatever he's
looking for on an entire planet you're
his aren't you that's hundreds of
islands lots of villages this is our guy
I'll be damned so his kids with the help
of this whale goo Enthusiast and the
most immoral marine biologist since
George Costanza he'll search for two
hours the the whale the whaling boat
what was behind the decision to give the
captain
a Australian or New Zealand accent but
make uh Brett or Jermaine which one is
which Concord is it but make Jermaine do
do American
I'm hoping that was Jermaine pulling a
camel where it's like you didn't have to
do this but I guess since you're in the
movie you trained first he's also yoked
he doesn't take off his shirt but he's
Jermaine did like three rounds of like
clenbuterol steroids or something and
they didn't let him take a show he's
like I thought I got to Dive In The
Water rip my shirt off it's business
time
we're gonna cut that but you do have a
dance number we are doing a Bollywood
dance
[Music]
whatever that guy he's got to be in like
Avatar three because all he does is lose
an arm he's coming back both Edie Falco
and coming back Clement are like and
he's Rich these are teases for their
Avatar three prominent if I didn't see a
skull getting crushed then I'm assuming
they're they're alive and well yeah I
mean they got to because these are these
are almost just like teasing future
which I like I like the the Moby Dick
like sea captain classic I mean they're
tropes but he yeah he does them so well
he's doing he Avatar one doesn't really
do this but he's he's Dark Universe sing
a little in this one he's definitely
setting up like the sequels yeah a
little bit like you know because he's
got the Sigourney Weaver stuff too like
right people already tried to bring back
Michelle Rodriguez who was like no I
can't be brought back to life in two
franchises
he's like no get in the water or what
man what is dead may never die like
yeah because there wouldn't even be a
good reason for them to break her she
was just a helicopter pilot she wasn't
like vital to the war effort like wow
well they're saying these costs like but
they still have dollars they still have
the dude from like the hottie and the
naughty he's still there helping out
that's true you've got me there and um
beside the science
Ribisi has a has a zoom call yeah but
they got rabisi back for a zoom call
like good for him I hope he's more
problems I hope they put a golf course
on Pandora and he's just you just see
him
he's in like the Paul Riser Burke role
you gotta have him back exactly he's got
a like a big send-off yeah uh all right
keep watching green time before finally
finding what he was looking for an
excuse for James Cameron to park a sub
incredible restraint to wait that long
before popping a sub
himself
you see one sci-fi sequel about saving
space whales see this one but isn't it
weird that there's two of them in an
experience that is awe-inspiring in a 3D
IMAX theater looks like a screensaver on
your TV at home and absolute crap here
on YouTube that for all its flaws kept
movie theaters in business for just a
little bit longer and kept audiences
from having to live in their actual
reality for three precious hours
you're right James you were more right
than you ever could have known
I see you less and less these days in
the navi Sigourney tweener the wrong kid
died
Tater took
C was angry that day my friends Chief
Reeve Kate Inlet what'd we do in the
shallows are you pulling my tail
securing
the past you read
the the next pulse checking
um or the temple to let you know you
know that you're communicating with
someone which one is stupider well I
think this one is dumb because you don't
you don't need to do it like people do
this to cue the viewer like oh they're
talking to somebody but in real life
this they're they're touching it this is
pinch to talk right I believe they have
to activate it normally it wouldn't just
be always on like the earpiece is always
on that's why this is stupid yeah it's a
shame I feel like they're they could
have done well no that'd be stupid is to
have like some kind of like nature
ponytail braid way of communicating
across distances of like uh I mean we
have set up that the planet is sort of a
communication
it's like an internet like Sigourney has
that line in Avatar yeah yeah or like
the or like the fungus in Last of Us
like it's an underground Network it's
Communications boards yeah uh yeah well
um yeah I think they're both pretty dumb
but uh uh but yeah I I it makes sense to
that you have to pinch to activate it I
guess yeah well like a walkie-talkie
where you have to hold the button to
talk it's like just a neckline well the
thing that we point out in the way back
when the uh Avengers honest trailers
that there's nothing in their ears they
didn't have a prop or anything they're
just putting their finger to their ear
also if any of their human technology uh
breaks down on Pandora like what are
they how are they repent they don't have
like hottie and the naughty guy they
have microchips
we have the lab people
the science people or whatever they call
them all right I guess they're making
their own like microchips yeah that's
pretty high like it's funny that Jake's
all like oh Sky people this Sky people
yeah it's very like guy that came back
from semester abroad yeah you know
they're not from the sky they're from
Earth you've been there
it's not this is not a mystery to you
sir no but he's one of the good ones
yeah yeah he should not do Sky people it
says it's weird when he used it all
right keep playing
icky fire
I'm coming out Sonic flashbacks
anytime I see a blue creature drowning
yep
foreign
Go Fish
oh thank goodness this little guy's here
to tell the massive planetary crust
scooping bulldozer where to go right
over there yep that away that way yep I
mean Max never makes sense but God I
love him you got to put them in here
James Cameron will never find a time to
not put a Mecca the little guy is so
tidy
you wouldn't even be able to see that
little guy he's like nope right over
there it's a real make work job for this
um Planet crushing military yeah I love
his like that's that's the thing is like
he loves
um the natural world but he doesn't I
don't think his nature designs we've
talked about this before are very
appealing to me like all of his
creatures are like kind of yeah I still
don't love like everybody's kind of like
two lizardy fishy on Pandora not enough
yeah they all look like something that
would be on like the box art for like a
graphics card in like 2002 yeah but I do
think that he has great
um military like Mech designs and stuff
like that that his Machinery yeah I
think that he really has that dialed in
I I I mean there's some examples even in
this in this movie but Terminator 2 that
opening scene where we see just a little
tease of the future War I feel like that
sequence alone inspired like a decade of
sci-fi Warfare like almost every sci-fi
war that I can think of is like owes
something to that I mean to be the most
the most like visually uh affecting
sequence was when the humans land in
those ships that like their rocket
exhaust burned like just creates this
literal scorched Earth thing and the
base just kind of like lowers into place
like Starcraft or something it was just
very I know it's cool yeah uh all right
was that that I think that's it um but
that's not the other video Stay Stay uh
because well like And subscribe and hit
the Bell but we are gonna show you some
outtakes and then answer your questions
so let's see the outtakes
Walt Disney's releasing full TV shows
with half a movie's worth of plot Jimmy
C drops a three-hour Juggernaut into
Cinemas packed with enough action story
and World building to keep She-Hulk busy
for the next hundred years that box the
Disney trends of being meta jokian
rushed in favor of a sincere hard on its
sleeve epic about how humanity is a
disease that should be wiped out for
good
good job
hey kids let the blood of the colonizers
soak the roots of me oh
Story return of the motto oh yeah the
teary's in this well I'm afraid I just
blew myself semper feline curiosity
killed the cat make me one with
everything low expectations Chad Hayes
Beast Boy me tour part-time at Disney's
flight
Smurfette nevermind mayor of restown
Free Willy style fail whale Academy
Award winner Brendan Fraser
corals Jr
swim city
waveheart
Sea World the good one
[Music]
all right yeah good time uh let's dive
in to your questions
um Trevor copter asks be honest did you
ever think once it finally came out
Avatar 2 would actually reach the
heights it did uh did Terminator 2 and
Aliens bolster your faith did you think
that this would this would do the
numbers it did I I mean you know look
it's it's always a I I it certainly
wasn't a sure thing but with James
Cameron I I do always feel like he just
doesn't do it unless he feels like he
knows like it it's never like well we
gotta release Avatar 2 by this date for
this date this day he's just like I see
how this is going to come together the
technology is ready we're doing Avatar
too and he doesn't take that step unless
he feels like it's in the bag so his
confidence gives me more confidence
yeah I was I would not have I I look I
had faith that it would do well but when
he said this needs to make two billion
dollars to make its money back I was
like
that's what's so amazing about it is
that he can go so much bigger and the
audience will follow him you know like
the the franchise grows as much as it
needs to to realize what he wants to do
with it yeah yeah especially now that
the theater experience is for me at
least better than it was when the first
one came out because even if you
complain about the prices it's still
like all right it's a three and a half
hour movie but you know there's also
like actual food now and you can get a
drink you can like it's a more
comfortable experience and I think that
that also makes it worth it for people
to have gone out and spent all of the
money that we spent on the movie yeah
totally
um all right Matan valenski says can we
talk about how Jimbo I assume that's
James Cameron and uh John Landau keep
insisting that this film isn't animation
it sounds disrespectful to animation I
don't know if it's disrespectful because
I think that like they're it's
performance capture right so there's a
human being like uh right providing the
basis for the animators to literally
skin on top of and it's like animation
is more flexible than that and they
they're like creating something from
scratch which is like that's I don't
want to say cooler but like that that
there's more to it than just kind of
like rendering a human being's
performance it's I think
what we consider live action in 2023 is
really a hybrid of computer animation
and live action like if you want pure
live action like there are many lovely
a24 films that I recommend but if you're
watching a studio movie
almost every shot even when you don't
realize it is like their clothing the
background integrating effects and
things that they really shot so it was
one of the actors bloated that day like
the the amount of stuff that they are
changing now when you're doing it it's
you know basically they throw an
Instagram filter over everything
everything right so so unless you're
talking about pure animation like
minions where there's nothing that they
shot yeah everything else kind of does
fall into this weird hard to Define
hybrid category where it's like there
was some live action and then there's
some animation and they're they're
mixing them in ways we don't always know
about that's
um so let's go on to uh the rain Art
City update channel in the UK Avatar 2
had a tie in with cereal like Shreddies
is that like Wheaties over there I'm
assuming um
how should cereal be plugged into this
film all of Shazam too oh my God not all
uh Shazam too because that's like put a
commercial what would be a good what
would be a good product tie-in for
Avatar too
um cereal specifically or any can I go
let's break it out today it was Frosted
Flakes right where Tony the Tiger was
blue that's that makes sense I think
instead of um like a product tie-in to
be true to the spirit of the film there
should be a series of eco-terrorist
attacks across
the pipeline yeah some pipeline bombing
some uh some Dam busting some uh you
know some freeing the animals at a
factory farm that kind of thing and
they'll just like leave Avatar 3
um uh flyers and posters at the scene of
the crime oh and they can either or they
can just leave
yeah or in the blood of the of the
military-industrial complex yeah there
you go
um yeah
uh or I don't know nerds the candy
before they're just all eating nerds all
the time nerds ropes just a bunch of
aliens they wrap their ponytail around a
nerd's rope and they're like Flavor
that's like the one the one thing from
Earth the one Earth shipment that
they've been living off of for all this
time is just there was a huge container
of neurons they said uh the dream yeah
uh I will end with this um from Violet
6450. hey Danielle when are you gonna
play D D again I loved you on Miss mag
um mismatch yeah uh uh that's a
dimension 20 show Misfits and Magic um
so I uh if you follow me on the thingies
right now I'm doing a uh Star Trek it's
like every Monday night
um a Star Trek show where I'm doing the
sling in the dice
um and I'm gonna be doing some more dice
slanging I've got more stuff coming up
thank y'all for asking um but yeah I
know so if you enjoy watching me
um do the nerdiest thing you could
possibly watch me do unless you lived in
my own home then then I I will make sure
that I'm uh advertising those more
because I kind of just do them because I
like them because I'm not so is that
there's a tabletop role-playing Star
Trek game like you get to you're like a
Starship crew or whatever that's fun
yeah yeah we're we're yeah we um we are
on Mars and we make spaceships okay well
so you're not even it's so nerdy that
you don't even give yourself the role of
like Explorer yeah you're just like
working in a factory right
cabin designer you're a star Fleet
captain and you're but no okay no no no
we're not we're not too crazy it's not
even lower decks you're literally just
on a planet making things okay sure I
pick out the Linens
well much like James Cameron I just
closed my eyes and imagine adventures in
my own brain I don't I don't need an
excuse like that I just go like oh I'm
so yeah and the guy crushes his own
skull man it's hardcore all right well
we'll see you in your dreams um until
next Tuesday when we do the same show
again
um for an another sequel uh that didn't
do as well as the box office
um no skulls were crushed per se but
definitely some bags of candy and some
dreams some dreams
that's your clue for next week's honest
trailer uh thank you for joining us I
see you we'll see you next week bye-bye
[Music]
thank you